this is Startalk here we go this is Ryan
first quick comment I absolutely loved
the show and can't get enough of it
please keep it up alright then and now
for a question is it my understanding
that a black hole will just vanish and
disappear at the end of its life now you
just touched on this and I if that's so
and here's this question that's why I'm
reading it and a equals MC square - or
MC squared what happens to the energy
and all the particles oh so in a
banishing blackhole so since we just
learned you just said this yeah that
they some of them bad okay all black
holes evaporate okay every understanding
we have of quantum physics and
relativity has advanced to us by the
brain work of Stephen Hawking in fact is
called Hawking radiation the fact that a
black hole will evaporate its
evaporation is its energy field is so
intense that matter spontaneously spawns
in that energy field Wow and in so doing
the black hole loses mass that's it and
so the act of it's losing mass is
because it's sending matter and energy
out beyond its event horizon right so
it's evaporating not into thin air so I
bring into thin space okay but that
energy is recovered in the volume of
space into which it has evaporated so
there's no loss of equals mc-squared
it's still it's still intact
yeah because there's no loss of energy
what's even more amazing is every atom
that went in if I drop you into a black
hole right there's an accounting of that
a mysterious quantum accounting of every
particle of you that went in so that you
look at the particles that evaporate out
from the energy field right that tally
will come out equaling the tally of
atoms that went in in the first place
the black hole remembered what it ate oh
my god it's like a cosmic nightclub two
people in two people out you got it
this has been star talk radio Chuck
thanks for being on as alright I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson bidding you to keep
looking up
[Music]